we feel strongly that there is zero
conflict between performance standards
and creating fulfilling environment
there and and so first of all you had it
but but we try we create that clarity
because if you don't create that clarity
up front in particular that's again 2500
managers distribute out the company if
we don't give them the words in the
language to have that locked and loaded
it gets very difficult because when
they're talking to a patient care
technician and going through the annual
review and it's got the mission and
values box you can't let that get in the
way of the technical performance it's
it's important but it's got to be
separate now we also talked about the
linkage and that stronger mission and
values performance affects how the whole
team does but we believe step number one
is you have to have total clarity that
they are they are independent you can
have a very strong performer from a
technical point of view business point
of view a person who just closes a lot
of sales
who's terrible on the mission and values
stuff and for us that's unsustainable
they have to be reformed or go or you
can have the opposite someone's great on
mission and values fulfillment but we
can performance they have to go to
because in a community you can't afford
unless you have enough productive
citizens you can't afford to take care
of the homeless and you can't afford to
reinvest in the schools so it's it's
again we try to make decisions with that
metaphor and just as a community can't
then want someone who's really wealthy
but doesn't care and doesn't give any
money to the parks and as a jerk and and
it takes advantage of other people in
different ways you can't that's really
destroys the health of the village there
similarly having people who don't
contribute and don't show up for work
doesn't make for a sustainable village
so we use the metaphor we're very clear
intellectually up front and then you
recognize that there's always gonna be
some noise out there and that's
appropriate because the fact is if it
gets someone who's really strong a
mission of values you are willing to cut
a little slack on the performance side
and and vice-versa so so that's what we
go for it strong intellectual clarity
use of the village metaphor and so it's
common sense everybody kind of goes yeah
there's a little tension in the middle
but they're separate change the world